اهتمام تركيا بالعالم العربي ازداد
[موسيقى]
بالنسبه للاهتمام العربي في تركيا طبعا
لها تاريخ اولا هناك علاقات تاريخيه بين
الاتراك والعرب منذ اكثر من الف سنه
اهتمام تركيا بالعالم العربي ازداده وعيش
اصبح هناك الكثير من
المشاريع المشتركه التواصل او دفاع عن
القضايا الاسلاميه والعربيه بما فيها قضيه
فلسطين او حتى الربيع العربي كان هناك
طبعا دور تركي في يعني في ان تكون نموذجا
لمسار الديمقتي في العالم العربي تباين
بين السياسات التركيه والاوروبيه يعني جعل
اوروبا يدعم المعارضه في تركيا يرون ان
تغيير اردوغان سيفيد لهم من اجل املاء
املاء سياساتهم على تركيا بشكل اريح ولذلك
نرى ان هناك يعني دعم كبير جدا من امريكا
ومن اوروبا للمعارضه في تركيا